I'm coming to New York
every time when I here in New York this
on always pop up to my mind what why
start spreading the news doo doo doo
yeah this one's the fiancee I love you
New York oh you're going new school I'm
going old school I want to part of it
you don't know this a new york new york
really I don't know this on you too old
for me I'm too old for you Wow three
years 2 months in 5 days I'm definitely
more mature i am going to New York to
meet with Ryan Holliday Ryan Holliday
wrote a bunch of books basically about
book marketing he's all about book
marketing he helps people market their
books he is a agency doing it he's 28
years old has an insane resume was the
vp of marketing at american apparel and
now basically does a lot of a lot of
work helping authors market their books
somebody also asked to do a top 10 video
on him he said that's cool why don't I
help be in the video said oh that's
awesome and he's from Texas and we're
going to meet up in New York to shoot
his top 10 video which is interesting
because never done a top 10 video with a
person who was in the top 10 video is
introducing the top 10 video so not
really sure what I'm gonna do about that
if you guys have creative ideas leave it
in the comments below because I'm
definitely open to it and I think he's
pretty open to it too so we're meeting
at nine thirty in the morning this
coming Friday one shot up for you guys
is let me know creative ideas the second
one is for any of you guys who are in
New York I'm gonna be there just for the
Friday this Friday I have my Rhine
meeting at nine thirty in the morning I
don't know how long that will go let's
say until noon and then have to fly back
out in the evening so I've got a window
there of a couple hours and I've been to
New York so many times that I don't you
know I don't need to do a lot of the
touristy stuff Nina might make me buy
some things
I don't need to buy anything for the
wife in New York right do I need to buy
something for the wife in the air it's
any device something for the wife and
York but I still have some extra time so
for those of you who are in New York i'm
going to send an email out to the New
Yorkers on my list with Aweber you can
figure out what States people are from
so if you want to meet up with me chit
chat brains from your business one of my
favorite parts about traveling is
connecting with local entrepreneurs so
the easiest way probably is to get on a
newsletter list if you're not already on
it or just email me and hopefully we can
arrange a time to connect I'm going to
be around the Empire State Building i
believe so we'll probably meet around
there somewhere open to ideas for things
to do local coffee shop local cafe if
you have a business in New York City
that'd be pretty funky to go and check
out mita stuff x it's really original
new york or meet at starbucks nina just
wants a starbucks New York mug which is
what i need gonna need to buy so one
ideas you have for me to do with Ryan
holiday for his interview / top 10 video
something creative fun different and two
if you're in New York I want to meet up
get on the newsletter or email me and
let's figure out a time this friday
around noon ish I'm excited thank you
guys have a great weekend continue to
believe and see you next time
what isn't it how many videos have leave
everything and we'll see you soon Nina's
gonna miss me when I'm away oh you
should make a longer no but I already
got my plans line up what's your plan
what are you doing we going we gonna
come home and sleep yeah okay I'm always
worried about going away cuz she's gives
me like the biggest guilt trip of all
time no I don't give you biggest I can't
sleep best year I can't sleep and then I
always feel guilty that makes sure that
asleep oh when you know yeah but I just
asked you know beside the plan why are
you looking for one day though one night
one night without sleeping okay so
what's like then what's the what's the
cutoff point where one day that's it
yeah one night one night we already sick
see you soon yeah you got it right this
time see you soon anvil sees embassy you
soon